direction Magny-les-Hameaux à présent en
en parlait en début d'émission un
collectif de citoyens s'est formé en mai
dernier il demande l'enfouissement des
lignes à haute tension sur le quartier
du buisson pour en parler avec nous le
fondateur Pierre-Louis Brière et demande
du collectif Laetitia Marlin bonsoir et
Emmanuel boucher bonsoir alors Laetitia
marin Emmanuel boucher pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez décidé d'intégrer ce
collectif
comme vous voulez pour ma part en fait
voilà moi je suis habitante à
Magny-les-Hameaux depuis 2018 et ce qui
se passe c'est qu'en gros on est juste
en dessous vraiment des lignes
c'est vrai que bon bah déjà bon certes
ça fait pas très joli dans le paysage
mais ça peut être dangereux et c'est
vrai que ce qu'on nous a appris c'est
que depuis 2018 depuis que je suis
arrivée quand j'ai emménagé là-bas ce
qui se passe c'est que tous les
habitants enfin les anciens
propriétaires tout le monde nous a dit
ça doit être fait ça doit être fait mais
en gros ils ont vendu du rêve et au
final tout le monde se retrouve à se
dire mais il y aurait dû avoir quelque
chose de fait au final rien ne se fait
et maintenant mais c'est vraiment les
gens sont blasés déçus et enfin limite
on a du mal à les faire limite rentrer
dans le collectif parce qu'au final ils
y croient plus et c'est vraiment dommage
et on est là et on essaie vraiment de
les motiver ce sont les mêmes raisons
pour vous Emmanuel raison moi je suis
moins touché ce que je suis pas dans ce
quartier là de magny-les-maux tu fais un
tout petit peu plus loin mais c'est
surtout pour souvenir le collectif ce
qu'on est tous ensemble même si je peux
toucher directement et essayer de faire
en sorte que ce soit nombreux plus lié
de voix pour tenir un gain de cause
entre guillemets
alors en début d'émission vous nous
parliez des risques sanitaires liés à
ces lignes à haute tension quels sont
les risques et il y a eu des études qui
l'ont qui l'ont prouvé oui donc dans
tous les rapports officiels donc il y a
des risques qui sont mentionnés les
risques notamment de leucémie infantile
de cancer infantile qui ne concerne
particulièrement vu que la ligne passe
au dessus de la crèche l'école
maternelle le gymnase les aires de jeux
pour enfants donc il y a pas de
consensus sur ces risques mais ils sont
toujours évoqués ce qui suffit à nous
inquiéter
on parle notamment de cas de leucémie
infantile qui aurait eu dans le quartier
depuis quelques années on peut pas
prouver que c'est dû à ça mais c'est
qu'à existent existe
donc ça c'est vraiment la première
raison pour laquelle on se mobilise il y
a aussi c'est ce que d'effondrement
c'est une deuxième raison il y a le
risque de sécurité oui la ligne elle
s'est déjà décrochée et elle est tombée
dans la cour de l'école André Gide lors
de la tempête de 1999 et avec le
dérèglement climatique qui arrive c'est
des risques qui sont de plus en plus
probables donc voilà ça n'a plus trop de
sens de vivre avec une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête il y a également le
bruit
présent constamment exactement
c'est aussi une nuisance sonore donc
c'est aussi une question de cadre de vie
donc Laetitia toi tu habites juste en
dessous donc j'imagine que tu es plus
concerné que moi par le bleu
fréquemment on a remarqué alors qu'en
tant humide il y a ces petits
grésillements et il y a encore ben
justement je suis envoyé la petite vidéo
ça peut être le soir en pleine nuit donc
là on est en plein été il fait très
chaud les fenêtres sont forcément
ouvertes et il y a ce grésillement alors
il y a des fois ça va être aléatoire il
y a des fois ça va être beaucoup plus
souvent enfin ça peut être limite
constant et c'est vrai que 10 heures
quand il y a plus de bruit entendre le
bah c'est pas grave du tout et c'est
vrai qu'on se dit mais voilà mais au
final qu'est-ce que ça fait sur nous
parce que il y a un moment vraiment on
se pose des questions moi je peux
rajouter il y a vraiment enfin on se
pose de plus en plus de questions aussi
là dessus c'est que dans ma rue donc
tous ceux qui sont arrivés on va dire
depuis 20 à 40 ans et tout premier qui
était là
il y en a qui peuvent tomber gravement
malade alors encore une fois ça vient
pas forcément que de ça mais quelle est
l'influence on se pose vraiment la
question quelle est l'influence on va
dire sur les personnes qui tombent
malades qui a pu avoir ces lignes aux
tensions et ces lignes il y a 20 ans
elles étaient déjà présentes est-ce que
vous savez l'historique un peu de ces
lignes à haute tension alors on sait
qu'elle se sont là depuis au moins 40
ans
qui a un projet d'enfouissement qui
existe depuis
au moins 20 ans je dirais
voilà qui a failli faire à plusieurs
reprises et finalement le finalement ça
s'est pas fait
je sais pas exactement il y a eu
plusieurs revirements il y a plusieurs
communes notamment de l'agglomération
qui sont demandeuses de l'enfouissement
et c'est quand même des c'est quand même
des dossiers assez onéreux
donc voilà nous on est là justement pour
cette enfouissement se fasse pour qu'il
y ait une vraie mobilisation citoyenne
sur la ville qui sont en relais aussi
des demandes plus politiques de la
mairie oui oui le maire je l'ai
rencontré plusieurs fois il soutient
évidemment la démarche mais voilà on a
convenu de rester chacun dans son
couloir nous on est vraiment un
collectif citoyen et mobilisation
citoyenne apolitique et lui dans un
couloir plus politique et je pense que
c'est complémentaire notamment auprès
des principaux acteurs décisionnaires
sur ce dossier et justement RTE le
réseau de transport d'électricité vous
l'avez également contacté alors en fait
là on est plutôt dans une phase de
structuration interne pour être crédible
donc grandir être suffisamment nombreux
aussi voilà on est ici enfin on mobilise
aussi la presse locale on a eu un
article dans la Gazette de 50 ans en
Yvelines dans les nouvelles de cette
semaine normalement on a reçu un article
aussi pour se crédibiliser aussi en
interne par rapport aux membres du
collectif et au menu quoi qui comme
disait Laetitia sont parfois un peu des
abusés sur le sujet et après on va
entrer dans la troisième phase qui est
celle des rendez-vous donc très
prochainement avec l'agglomération qui
est de très bonne volonté pour ré-ouvrir
le dossier et donc ensuite on ira voir
avec l'agglomération RTE pour
pouvoir voir concrètement comment on
fait et après on ira voir les principaux
partenaires notamment le département et
la région pour voir les financements et
on essaiera d'avoir un calendrier
d'enfouissement le plus vite possible
mais voilà c'est un combat de longue
haleine donc on fait les étapes les unes
après les autres pour maximiser les
chances d'enfouissement pour le moment
pas de prise de contact avec RTE ni le
département des Yvelines ou quand même
une prise de contact à
la rentrée et vous le disiez il y a
quelques instants c'est un sujet qui
date d'énormément d'années il y a plus
de 20 ans notamment sur plusieurs villes
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
également Élancourt et la verrière
est-ce que vous avez pensé à vous unir à
d'autres habitants qui vivent la même
chose pour justement peser plus lourd
alors
j'ai pas eu de contact j'ai pas
connaissance de collectif
similaire
à Élancourt et la verrière
bien que leur dossier soit plus avancé
que les nôtres donc on est plutôt
contacté par les habitants de Saint-Rémy
au moins 15 20 qui nous ont contactés
c'est le prolongement de notre ligne ça
passe au dessus du des Hauts de
Saint-Rémy du quartier de beau plan et
lui aimerait faire d'une pierre de coups
et que
bénéficier aussi de l'enfouissement donc
on les accueille à bras ouverts merci
beaucoup Pierre Louis Brière Laetitia
Marlin et Emmanuel boucher d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes membre du
Collectif citoyen pour l'enfouissement
des lignes à haute tension de Manille
les ha